hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 9 video ding
dong the season is back and it was a
great episode this is how you do Walking
Dead finales and premieres are always
really big deals because it's a time to
clear the board shake the characters up
reset things if you need to get rid of
what didn't work the previous season so
the funny thing going into this like in
the last couple of weeks Robert Kirkman
is like a hundred percent not everybody
makes it out of this alive so we knew
people were gonna die we just didn't
know who it was gonna be and they went
in a very comic book direction which I
guess shouldn't be a surprise because
both Kirkman and Scott Gimple have said
they're moving in a more comic book
direction they said that as early as
season 5 so there were some really big
comic book moments in the episode I'm
gonna do top 10 WTF I'll try to explain
the comic book Easter eggs as I go along
it just for reference if you do want to
read along in the comics we are in the
middle of no way out that's the volume
that we're in so starting with number 10
goodbye wolves hello saviors if there's
one thing you don't do in The Walking
Dead it's threatened to kill a fan
favorite character and pretend like you
own the place
just perfect set up for Daryl to pull
the rug out from under with the bazooka
that is how you open an episode which is
why that is my new favorite opening
scene from any Walking Dead episode ever
[ __ ] are tougher than they look on a
number 9 WTF who is negan don't you dare
ask questions so this is just teasing
the idea that negan is going to be
coming sometimes sooner rather than
later because they cast Jeffrey Dean
Morgan he is super excited he said that
when he explained it to his mom who he
was playing on Walking Dead she was
heartbroken because he's that terrible
if you haven't read the comics or trolls
haven't spoiled it for you
negan is just like the uber governor
broader Kirkman explained when it came
time to introduce the character the
reason why they wanted to use him is
because the comic could be going on for
a long time they had reached their 100th
episode so it was an anniversary of
sorts and they wanted to let the comic
book fans know that there was still a
whole bunch of stuff in store Robert
Kirkman has said that he'll continue
writing the comic book til the end of
time the negan became the surprise
[ __ ] of the comic books you thought
you met some villains no this is a real
villain so just expect from here on out
each episode for us to get closer and
closer to saviors especially with the
lake of fire I was thinking that they
would blow the walkers up in that cloud
of smoke would alert the other saviors
as to where the safe zone was we'll see
if there's any fallout
next week but remember Dara blew up all
those saviors so presumably the people
that they report to are gonna wonder why
they didn't come back when the show does
comic book stuff there's always the
question of timing so I I think we might
see a few other comic book things before
we see negan number eight WTF Gabriel
nuts up agrees to take Judith I promised
him finding a certain amount of
redemption for being an asset his logic
and the episode was a little time he why
me but you get the idea Gabriel feels
redeemed but he's still a little bit
nuts in the head God answered our
prayers to save the safe zone because
God gave us the courage to save the safe
zone ourselves even after all this if
you still hate Gabriel's character I
feel like you're in the right you're
still meant to look at him with one wary
eye like your one eye that's left which
we'll talk about in a second number
seven WTF Denise in the wolf the wolf
gets super creepy he's like Hannibal
Lecter outside of the cage you were
right I am changed I am so happy they
killed him off he was such a bag of
dicks and it may not have come across in
her scenes but Denise nuts up so to
speak like she finds the courage to save
Carl do what needs to be done in the
infirmary it's not as big of a
transition as Gabriel who was just like
the biggest coward in the world and then
like grabs the machete and it's like God
gave us the strength to save the save
zone ourselves but number 6 WTF Daryl
saves the day with the fuel truck
creating the lake of fire to attract the
walkers which neutralizes a lot of the
herd and gives him the opportunity to
take out the rest one of the funniest
moments in the episode was when Colin
hops in the cab and Daryl's like dude
what's what's going on
England shrugs I don't know I just got
here like they're waving their hand at
the last couple of episodes that Cullen
has missed since he crawled out from
under that dumpster
speaking of which number five this is
actually a pretty crazy one they almost
put Glenn underneath another dumpster I
was so happy they didn't kill Glenn I
would have been so mad because it would
have completely invalidated that whole
first half of the season with the
dumpster which was problematic by itself
I know a lot of people complain about
the Walking Dead doing things that they
don't like or things that they feel are
stupid but really like the most broad
spectrum stupid thing you could do is a
writer is write a new plot twist that
completely invalidates some stuff that
you've already done Gabriel for instance
if they had killed baby Judith at the
end of the episode it would have
completely invalidated his arc from the
episode so there are twists for the sake
of twists in their twist that help
characters evolve
so it's almost like Sasha and Abraham
were killing the dumpster as Glenn was
slowly climbing underneath it in that
scene number four WTF Morgan finishes
off the wolf that has become a walker
saying sorry as he does it almost like
he's telling all of us and telling
Carroll sorry for being such a douchebag
the last couple of episodes
I saved this guy for me not for everyone
else you guys can let me know in the
comments if you agree with what Carol
said you didn't save him for us you
saved him for you number three WTF
Jesse's family gets annihilated in rapid
succession
now I didn't hate Jesse's character but
I was so pumped up with the way they did
this because it's a very comic book
moment this is right out of the comics
walkers mass on Jesse's son in the
comics she rushes to save him and in
doing so gets herself killed you can
even see this panel here right out of
comics rick has to chop her hand off so
that they can keep going in the number
two WTF Ron finally pulls the trigger
but he's actually trying to kill Rick as
if like all this stuff that's happening
his family dying is Rick's fault
Michonne runs him through with a really
awesome katana kill but we learned that
he has shot Carl's eye out I know it's a
little timing why me because it's like
you know how did the bullet hit him is
he gonna have brain damage will his
personality be altered what parts of his
brain have been damaged we'll find out
in the next couple of episodes because
there are a couple ways that you can get
shot in the heads that you will survive
but depending on the parts of the brain
that are damaged you can either lose
critical function part of your
personality could change you could lose
reasoning capabilities a whole bunch of
stuff could happen so I'm really excited
to see where they take his character
because he was this really hopeful
person before this like he grabbed Ron's
hand the guy who had just tried to kill
him in the garage so now maybe as Rick
starts to get more hopeful about this
new world that he was talking about in
that last speech with Carl Carl's going
to go in the opposite direction and get
more cynical and finally my number one
WTF Rick's new world that he's teasing
versus negan's new world I feel like the
second half of the season is going to be
a clash of ideologies where Rick is this
hopeful person like look what we could
accomplish when we work together we're
gonna make this safer we're gonna
fulfill Diana's dream of society coming
back despite the apocalypse
negan is they're gonna tease out through
the rest of the season is more of a only
the strongest survive person and if you
have read the comics and you want to
talk about negan stuff character
development for the characters that are
still
on the show please use spoiler tags
because I do think they're gonna do some
very big comic book moments some comic
book places we just don't know how soon
they're going to do them I think it's
not a question of if I think it's a
question of when but let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from the episode and I almost forgot
there is a new round of the giveaway -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll be doing weekly Walking Dead
videos just like normal if I have time
for a Q&A I'll do a Q&A but there's a
game of Thrones trailer that just posted
so I'm mostly gonna be focusing on that
tomorrow a whole bunch awesome stuff if
there's any special Walking Dead bonus
videos that you guys want just let me
know in the comments
yay for Walking Dead I'm so happy with
this episode it was great while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for that Game of Thrones
trailer that just posted and you can
click here for my Deadpool Easter eggs
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight